check this out heart attacks at record
levels after pandemic this is the
telegraph story page 15. what do you
mean heart attacks at record level after
the pandemic so
what page is that on right page six okay
heart attacks at record level after the
pandemic
there you go okay thank you
um so here we go record numbers of
post-pandemic heart attacks
hospitalizations exceeded 84 000 cases
in England for 20 21 2022 making a 7 000
case increase underlying delayed uh
detection concern says official data a
new uh NHS campaign pushes early uh
action urging individuals to dial 999
when encountering heart attack symptoms
like chest tightness and sweating aiming
for better survival odds emphasizing
Professor Nick Linker NHS National
Clinical Director for heart disease
every moment that passes during a heart
attack increases heart muscle damage
please call 999 so you have the best
chance to have full recovery a 250
million pound NHS funding boost for
winter with plans to not for 900 extra
bet seeks to address pandemic including
service disruptions and higher heart
related deaths while heart Charities
emphasize the urgency of timely care
okay this is just in UK these reports
are coming out here you saw the story of
Caleb White another 17 year old kid from
three high school basketball player in
Alabama dies after collapsing on court
we just had LeBron's son went through
that brownie we were all looking forward
to the day for him to play with us and
and the the World Cup female soccer
player from I don't know Columbia or
something collapsed twice how many
people on the news they're doing the
news and the lady drops comedians
dropping politically so now we don't
know what it is we want to know what it
is but what we do know what's happened
the last three years people trust big
Pharma less people trust the governments
let governments plural worldwide
everywhere governments less people trust
World Health Organization less people
trust NIH less CDC less all of these
guys less and all people are saying is
listen I'm sick and tired of just being
seen as the sicker I am the more money
you make off of me the more hospital
beds are filled the more money you make
off of me yeah empty beds don't make
hospitals money we need hospitals to be
full to make the hospital money when you
start looking at it from this angle
rather than the incentive being healthy
or you are the better you do a couple
years ago an insurance company came up
to us they had a program called Vitality
okay I don't know if you remember this
time or not Vitality it was handling oh
yeah yeah Hancock is a good memory so
Hancock you know what their memory the
the product was yeah I remember that
well sell you an insurance policy and if
you wear this Fitbit year-round and the
Fitbit reports back to our insurance
company that you're moving your body and
exercising your cost of insurance is
going to decline every quarter or so
what a product you're incentivizing
people to not need their life insurance
policy let me say that again you're
incentivizing the insurance company is
flat out telling you listen man I want
you to live longer okay please exercise
so you can live longer so I don't have
to pay you the death benefit in case you
die and if you keep exercising and
moving your body I will charge you less
for the insurance policy that's what you
call Compassionate capitalism where
you're using it in a way to say listen
let's keep hospitals emptier I'm going
to give you know a certain incentive for
keeping people healthier you know you
don't hear Governors or presidents
talking about guys start reading some
business books start exercising stop
eating at some of these places that's
fast food you don't hear those
conversations you if I told you right
now a president that talks about the
Border you would say Trump if I told you
a president that talks about the number
one world crisis in the world is white
supremacy you would say Biden if I told
you the biggest crisis in the world is
climate change you would think about AOC
Greta or some of these guys but if I
told you name me one political leader
that talks about go read some damn books
go exercise take care of your health
stop eating shitty food you can't think
about out a candidate no you can't no
well this is the incentive program so
going back to the enemy is real but I
think the other side skeptical people
are like listen man it's about time we
go address these guys I'll just say one
thing I can't think of a candidate and
that would be RFK not I mean it was so
like fascinating to watch the debate or
whatever the potential debate that he
had with the guy Dr Peter Hotes meaning
you got you got RFK who's who actually
admitted to taking the vaccine but it
says it's okay to question the vaccine
especially the operation warp speed and
Rush down the pike and what's happening
with that but here you got this dude how
old is he 70 65 Jack Jack diesel working
out then you've got Dr Peter Hotes
vaccine Advocate I'm telling you under
that white coat it ain't looking good
fast food addict exactly so you know
ultimately what does it come down to are
you going to be proactive about your
health or gonna be reactive hospitals
you know what we call it yesterday a
hotel for sick people unless those beds
are not filled basically the vacancy
they're not making any freaking money
exactly so I mean what did we learn
during covet just take the jab take the
vaccine don't ask any questions nobody
was saying bro get the outside work
out get some sun eat healthy stay active
sweat but that's the mess but there's no
money in that who makes money the gyms
okay Fitness instructors that's awesome
but that ain't big Pharma that's not
their business model that's how they
make their money you know it's with sick
people you know you and I in the
insurance business and Tom you're an
insurance executive I mean we can call
you an insurance executive it's you know
have you been a president and a CSO an
insurance company I was adopted by the
industry so when questions when
questions asked about life insurance how
to get even with the life insurance
company you know my statement always
don't cancel your policy yeah what do
you mean don't die don't cancer no no no
don't cancel your policy what does that
mean don't cancel your policy because
the insurance company banks on
eventually you canceling your policy
yeah and when you do that premium goes
to who the insurance company okay so but
if you keep your policy and you
eventually die they have to pay out so
if you want to get even with the
insurance company buy your policy never
cancel that is the wisest thing you can
do because what happens with insurance
companies is you buy an insurance policy
a 2008 crisis happens a covet happens
what's the first thing people cancel
insurance policy what they don't realize
the insurance policy you got you got it
when you were 33 years old healthy and
it was good you got to prove so you
prefer to lead you're paying costs of
insurance is nothing but a crisis
happened and now you canceled it say you
were paying 100 bucks a month I'm just
using basic math now you're 43 years old
okay you got a wife and three kids and
you're like I gotta go out there and get
an insurance policy well now you're
older you're sicker you're not healthier
now your insurance policy is no longer
100 bucks a month now you got to pay two
three four whatever the number is going
to be depending on based on your health
so but people cancel it if you keep it
you're going to be healthy we need more
policies that say look let's incentivize
people that don't use health insurance
let's give credit to people that take
care of their health give them a tax
incentive every year where you're not
going to the doctor all the time when
you are keeping a certain weight on your
body and all this stuff let's give
incentives for staying healthy if we
could do that we have a better Society
we can easily increase our life
expectancy we can easily increase our
lifestyle we can do those types of
things but those types of policies don't
make money exactly and Pat it's funny
you said that because you know being a
veteran just like you you I got my car
insurance through USAA and they have
this thing that you could add it's
called safe pilot so the app is tracking
no matter if you're driving Pat and you
pick up your phone it docks you if
you're talking like this if you're a
speaker so now I'm trained now to where
I'm like if it ain't important I'm not
on my phone 30 I get discount per month
because I'm not on my phone talking
driving and being unsafe ultimately
you're instead of talking about
rewarding people who are driving safe or
being healthy and doing all that and
obviously I won't go here but obviously
I can talk for days about people
canceling their life insurance policies
that's my business model but especially
if in your 30s 40s 50s even 60s
keep that policy as you get older it
gets way more expensive especially if
you're trying to qualify for insurance
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
foreign
[Music]